الدكتور ساجو ماثيو معنا الآن
طبيب رعاية أولية واختصاصي الصحة العامة
الدكتور ماثيو جيد لرؤيتك شكرًا
لوجودك هنا أريد أن أعرف ما
كان رد فعلك الأولي على حقيقة أنهم
يعطون الرئيس
ما هو علاج تجريبي
لقد سمعنا للتو من الرئيس التنفيذي هناك ولكن
هل لديك أي مخاوف كطبيب بشأن
علاج رئيس الولايات المتحدة
بدواء لم تتم
الموافقة عليه من قبل إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) نعم صباح الخير
كريستين الكثير من
الأحداث التي حدثت خلال الـ 24 ساعة الماضية
و  أولاً ، أود أن أتمنى
للرئيس ترامب بصفته منصبًا
لرعاية مرضى coven 19
، الشفاء العاجل للإجابة على
أسئلتك تحديدًا حول التجديد ،
هذا علاج جديد ،
إنه في الواقع نسخة أكثر تطوراً
كريستي من بلازما
النقاهة بالبلازما  حيث تأخذ فقط
الأجسام المضادة
لمريض كان مريضًا بشدة
بالتساهم 19 جنبًا إلى جنب مع البلازما
مع منتجات الدم الأخرى والمعلومات
انظر إلى شخص يتعافى من كوبي 19. مع هذا العلاج الجديد ، يكون الجسم المضاد أحادي النسيلة عبارة عن جسم مضاد أكثر تحديدًا نسخة أنظف وما تفعله هو أنك تستهدف على وجه التحديد فيروس covet 19 ، لذا إذا فكرت في هذا التفسير العلمي هناك الكثير من الأمل في أن المشكلة كريستي هي أننا لا نمتلك بيانات كافية عن هذا الجسم المضاد أحادي النسيلة ونحصل على هذا ، وليس لدينا إذن استخدام طارئ تم إعطاؤه إذا كنت ستفعل ذلك على أساس الحاجة الرحيمة إلى الرئيس ، أنا قلق بالطبع من أي نوع من الأدوية التجريبية في هذه المرحلة في خضم جائحة ومعرفة أن الرئيس ترامب حقًا هو رجل قوي وواثق من أنه يجب عليك الحصول على موافقته حتى تحصل على هذا يجب أن نرى ما إذا كان يعمل بالتسريب ، فإليك سؤالي الآخر لأننا نتلقى كلمة هذا الصباح بأنه قد تم إعطاؤه أيضًا جرعته الأولى من rem المستحق أم لا ، هل هناك أي قلق  حول
إعطاء هذين العقارين جنبًا
إلى جنب مع بعضهما البعض
سؤال جيد كريسي لم أقرأ
أي
مقال علمي يتحدث عن
موانع
أو تفاعل إذا فكرت في ذلك ،
فإن الأجسام المضادة أحادية النسيلة هي نوع من
تنشيط نظام المناعة الطبيعي وأه ريمديزافير هو  يقلل حقًا من
تكاثر الفيروس في الجسم ،
لذلك إذا كنت تريد أن يكون هناك مساران منفصلان
ولكنك تعلم أنه من المثير للاهتمام أنه في
غضون 24 ساعة انتقل من الأعراض الخفيفة
إلى الحصول الآن على استحقاق rem والذي
يُعطى عادةً للمرضى
الذين يخضعون للعلاج بالأكسجين وكذلك  على حد
علمنا
أنه لا يتلقى حاليًا الأكسجين